[Musique]
et je veux dire, peu importe ce qu'il va commencer à
tirer, ils veulent tous ce que vous avez
et ils nous tueront tous
jusqu'à ce qu'ils l'obtiennent
[Musique]
journalistes drôles dans le coin ah c'est
ton anniversaire
je suis  30 ans je porte une chemise hawaïenne
pour toi mon petit ami m'a largué pas d'impôt
mettons le feu nous voulons juste
parler de draw Thayer c'est ton
petit ami Ryan je suis désolé ce que je sais que
tu es un espion c'est une longue histoire à
tout vous expliquer front certaines
mauvaises personnes sont après moi d'autres après
vous si nous ne livrons pas ce colis
vous avez eu beaucoup de gens vont mourir
de mourir n'ayant jamais été en Europe ou
voulez-vous aller en Europe et mourir  avoir
été en Europe
pourquoi sont-ce mes deux seules options
[Musique]
un groupe terroriste achète une série d'
assassinats beaucoup d'
innocents vont mourir à moins que vous ne fassiez confiance récemment pour vous
demander de l'aide c'est réel et je
pense honnêtement que je suis choqué
tu es incroyable et je veux que tu le possèdes
[Musique]
tu as  un vrai instinct pour cette Scylla
salut ok sans toi et puis quoi t'es
la patronne et pourtant t'as pas sacrifié
une once de féminité c'est la
Beyonce du gouvernement
toi